[Musique]
bonjour merci jimmy bonjour michel
durand bonjour directeur d'edf en
martinique nous allons parler avec vous
ce matin de la transition énergétique et
comment elles se déroulent en martinique
alors rappelons les objectifs de la loi
de transition énergétique
concernant la martinique c'était des
chiffres qui était notamment annoncé
durant l'année 2015 50 % d'autonomie
énergétique en 2020 100 % d'autonomie
énergétique en 2030 ça ce sont les
objectifs donc fixé de ce point de vue
en 2017
comment a été justement la consommation
d'électricité des martiniquaises et des
martiniquais est ce qu'en 2010 est
justement on a franchi des étapes pour
pouvoir atteindre cet objectif sans
objectif mais effectivement vous avez
rappelé les objectifs et en 2010 est le
premier point qui est notable c'est que
en matière de consommation d'électricité
on a eu une baisse de consommation c'est
la deuxième année de suite et cette
baisse ça les a rapprochés de tous les
efforts qui ont été engagés par
l'ensemble des martiniquais
accompagné par la ctm par edf par le ce
même alors réduire leur consommation
d'électricité soyons précis vous
parlerai cela laisse elle a été là de 2
5%
alors dans ces 2 5% la grande majorité
vient de ses efforts en matière de
maîtrise de la consommation d'énergie
alors si on prend une image globalement
sur une année comme 2017 par tous les
efforts qui ont été engagées on a gagné
pratiquement une semaine de consommation
d'électricité ce qui est énorme alors
derrière il ya il ya beaucoup de choses
il ya les chauffe eau solaire qui qui se
déploie de plus en plus en martinique
qui évite de consommer de l'électricité
pour chauffer de l'eau à domicile on a
les lampes led qui sont beaucoup
développés on en a encore distribué
cette année plus de 15000 dans les
logements sociaux et puis il ya eu des
programmes pour que les led soient
accessibles à des prix compétitifs
il ya tous les programmes qui sont
engagés aussi sur les frigos haute
performance sur les les climatiseurs
haute performance tous ces sujets
ibou tabous ont permis en 2010 est de
réduire la consommation 2 5% alors il
faut garder ce rythme 2,5 pour cent ou
est ce suffisant pour atteindre les
objectifs que nous indiquions la route à
l'heure où est-ce qu'il faut augmenter
la cadence le rythme est bon puisque
quand on se projette effectivement sur
ses ambitions d'être à 50% d'énergies
renouvelables donc décarbonés et 100 %
en 2030 l'hypothèse qu'on a fait c'est
d'être sur une consommation stable dans
les dix ans qui viennent
donc on voit qu'en baissant la
consommation de 2 5% on est dans la
bonne dynamique donc c'est positif
et tout ça faut le rappeler si on est
engagé dans cette dynamique c'est
d'abord pour éviter d'émettre des gaz à
effet de serre du co2 est préservée
globalement notre planète
et puis faire de la martinique une île
qui est basé sur une autonomie
énergétique avec désirs dire alors le
lien entre parce que l'autonomie
énergétique énergies renouvelables on
mélange tout ça qu'est ce que ça fait
mais autonomie énergétique
qu'est ce que ça signifie concrètement
si on comprend bien c'est qu'il faut que
la martinique dépendre moins des
importations pour son énergie pour je
dirais sa vie au quotidien industriels
ou dans les foyers quoi enfin voilà
économique ou d'un loup dans les foyers
et d'entreprises où effectivement 7,7
cette loi nous emmène à une ambition qui
est de d'essayer de prendre le maximum
de choses qui sont disponibles en
martinique renouvelables de surcroît
donc qui se sont remplacés rapidement
océans le surchauffeur sous le choc le
solaire le soleil levant pour faire en
sorte qu' on est une indépendance en
matière d'énergie et on soit pas
dépendant de l'importation d'énergie et
de surcroît d'énergie fossile donc en
particulier le charbon ou le fioul qui
quand on les utilise émettent des gaz à
effet de serre donc l'ambition qui est
en route
c'est celle là et pour arriver à cette
ambition mais il ya deux sujets il ya
maîtriser notre consommation c'est à
dire ne pas
gaspiller l'énergie qu'on produit et
puis deuxième point c'est c'est produire
plus d'énergie renouvelable et tout ça
il faut toujours bien bien se mettre en
perspective que c'est une opportunité de
surcroît en terme d'emploi et d'activité
économique alors lamartine on va y venir
ce chantier alors edf et en est à son
coeur mais vous n'êtes pas tout seul il
y à aussi donc tout ça repose sur un
programme pluriannuel de l'énergie qui
est déterminé qui est fixé les
orientations énergétiques une bonne
partie des orientations énergétiques que
de la martinique est bien sont fixés par
les aiguilles de la ctm par les
conseillers territoriaux donc vous avez
des partenaires dans cette affaire c'est
tf1 alors yade m
ce même et ses organismes satellites
aussi de tout à fait alors le premier le
premier acte fondateur c'est c'est
d'abord un acte politique qui réalisait
par le politique et par l'état c'est
effectivement la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie et celle là
ce document là il est sous la
responsabilité de la ctm et de l'état
représenté par le préfet donc c'est un
document de fondateurs qui était elle
donc c'est la permière est annuel ouais
c'est la crise en termes de risque 18
2023 et là on va commencer à travailler
sur la période qui va aller jusqu à 2026
donc ça permet de se projeter sur de
quoi sera fait finalement l'énergie en
martinique dans cinq six ans ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça se travaille il
est fait en martinique avec tous les
acteurs qui sont les acteurs centraux de
l'énergie edf en tant que gestionnaire
système électrique et commercialisateur
d'électricité mais aussi le syndicat
mixte l'énergie qui est propriétaire des
réseaux edf exploite pour son compte
l' agence de développement et une
maîtrise de l'énergie l'ademe donc tous
les acteurs participent à cette
construction et puis derrière on pilote
on a une réunion pas plus tard que ce
matin pour piloter cadence et
l'avancement de cette transition
énergétique et le développement à la
fois des énergies renouvelables et puis
à la fois les offres qu'on fait pour que
les martiniquais puisse réduire leur
facture d'électricité justement alors
voilà donc il ya les pouvoirs publics
les partenaires publics qui sont engagés
dans dance est dans ses objectifs
et puis il faut bien sûr que ça suive au
niveau des des usagers de la population
et de ce point de vue est-ce que vous
avez des actions aussi pour comme on dit
sensibiliser impliquer davantage les uns
et des autres jimmy ou moins dans cette
politique de prix énergétiques et de
réduction de la consommation
il ya beaucoup d'action de qui sont
récurrentes qui existe depuis longtemps
ce toujours sur la maîtrise de l'énergie
on en fait dans les écoles on est encore
formé plus de 3000 élèves cette année
aux bons gestes aux éco gestes pour
réduire leur facture d'électricité
on fait beaucoup d'accompagnement télé
radio pour pour sensibiliser tout à
chacun sur sur l'intérêt d'économiser et
de réduire sa facture d'électricité
on fait aussi beaucoup d'accompagnement
pour les 40000 martiniquais qui sont en
situation de précarité énergétique on
appelle précarité énergétique et en 2017
c'est un domaine sur lequel on a
beaucoup travaillé de travailler avec
les ccas avec la ctm pour être au plus
près des 40000 martiniquais qui ont du
mal à payer leurs factures et qui au
travers de gestes simples ou de ou
d'accompagnement peuvent travailler sur
la réduction de leur facture
oui parce que rapidement bon c'est une
affaire qui sera longue
faut bien comprendre à leur transition
énergétique ça ça indique bien que c'est
par petits pas presque que cette affaire
va se dérouler d'autant que la
martinique part de loin en étant que des
territoires d'outre-mer concernant
justement les énergies renouvelables il
ya peu de temps près de 100 % quasiment
plus de 90% en tout cas de notre énergie
provenant d'énergies fossiles donc c'est
une vraie révolution qui pourrait donc
voilà alors c'est une vraie révolution
sur le domaine des énergies parce que ça
fonctionne comme ça du jour au lendemain
on a voulu parler de la maîtrise de
l'énergie sur le domaine de la
production d'énergie
2010 est une année a été une année sur
lequel on a on a stagné finalement en
matière de volumes d'énergie
renouvelable on a eu une année en plus
une fin d'année qui était qui était
assez nuageuse on a eu les cyclones qui
ont beaucoup mobilisé beaucoup de monde
et edf en particulier mais au-delà de ça
on a eu une année très nuageuse qui fait
que la production solaire a été un peu
plus basse qu'en 2016 mais quand on se
projette en 2018 et 2019
eh bien on a devant nous quelques
éléments qui vont nous permettre de
faire des pas en avant sur le
pourcentage d'énergies renouvelables
d'abord la centrale de trinité la
centrale biomasse qui elle toute seule
va faire 10 7 % d'énergies renouvelables
on a des éoliennes à grand rivière qui
sont les plus grandes éoliennes de la
caraïbe qui sont en train d'être
construite et qui vont démarrer pour fin
2018 qu'ils vont faire 14 mégawatts donc
ça commence à être des grosses éoliennes
qui vont des marins 2018 et qui vont
permettre ces deux éléments vont
permettre finalement de faire un bond en
avant significatif en matière d'énergies
renouvelables et en parallèle on a dû
solaire qui continue à se développer
on voit que le marché du solaire
commencent à se redynamiser il ya des
tarifs de rachat de l'électricité
solaire qui ont été augmentées par
l'état français
donc on commence à avoir des nouveaux de
la rentabilité pour tout à chacun à
réinstaller des panneaux solaires chez
lui une dernière question vraiment
quelques secondes je peux pas vous avoir
là au micro une pas vous parler vous
avez fait allusion d'ailleurs à la
centrale de trinité
la centrale électrique de du galion avec
l' usine de biomasse où en est on à
quelques jours du début de la saison
cannière saison sucrière comment alors
raccordement que ça suit son cours
je suis vous savez c c si une centrale
qui appartient à le biome a donc oui
c'est de mon côté j'ai pas le détail de
toutes les opérations elles sont en
cours mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que m edf a quand même une vie
nous on va racheter l'électricité et en
tant que gestionnaire de système ce
qu'on a devant nous c'est un début de
mise en service de la centrale
au mois de mars donc ça veut dire que de
toute évidence tout ce qui est
raccordement à la sucrerie avance merci
michel durand directeur merci à vos meux
martinique d'avoir participé à ça au
caddie bonne journée à vous merci bonne
journée